[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap on a weekend to chill
after a roasting week
40 degrees Centigrade at 104 Fahrenheit
in old money these are temperatures I
associate with Death Valley not the
Thames Valley and if you're not chilling
maybe you're traveling so many of us are
boarding Planes Trains and Automobiles
as school holidays begin so much of
today's show will be dedicated to a
simple question can we have
climate-friendly flight can we board a
plane guilt-free I've been asking lots
of people about it
you can look back at this week with
words records obliterated apocalyptic
infernos it looks like a war zone or in
numbers
40.3 degrees Centigrade more than 60
homes burned down hundreds of Acres of
Farmland up in smoke but to me its
significance is as a warning an acrid
Taste of the future
the UK is facing its first ever
reduction heat warning the temperatures
are possibly topping 40 degrees celsius
by tomorrow breaking the record for the
country's hottest ever day
well I've been a meteorologist for about
30 years and I've never seen the charts
that I've seen today to see the
brutality of the heat that we're
expecting tomorrow is quite astounding
by advices have been here in this area
of Woodland since around one o'clock
fighting a really large fire around the
size of five football pitches we're
experiencing these record brutal
temperatures because of human induced
climate change I know we don't want to
hear it but that really is what's
driving the hot weather that we've
experienced across Western Europe well
we talk about unprecedented heat and
that is certainly the case here in Wales
where they've broken the temperature
record today not once but twice Britain
should no longer think of itself as a
cold country
a new record temperature has been set
the village of coningsby in Lincolnshire
has hit
40.3 degrees Celsius
seeing temperatures well over 40 degrees
Celsius and not only being the hottest
location in the UK today but being the
hottest British place on record the
London fire brigade has just declared a
major incident in response to a huge
surge in fires across the capital today
all of the things that we've collected
from all the places we've been the
jewelry that I was left from my
grandparents when they passed a few
years ago
it's all gone from London to
Lincolnshire to Yorkshire flames and a
warning that wildfires could become more
common in the UK because of climate
change
this heat wave was made hotter by
climate change and one of the drivers of
that is Aviation well flying opens up
the world it allows business trips to
New York Hindus in Ibiza maybe a family
reunion in India the appetite for travel
and the tech to satisfy it have
transformed our lives but the somewhat
unnatural act of flying requires
extraordinary power and this stuff
jet fuel delivers it now to deliver the
same energy that's in this can a battery
would need to be about 40 times the
weight that's a huge challenge if you
need to fly and it is this
energy density which gives jet fuel its
massive Edge now there are going to be a
few figures in this show but no
apologies as they're truly revelatory
and bring some wishful thinking down to
earth
first quantity we burn 10 tons of jet
fuel every second across the world
that's an Olympic-sized swimming pool
every three minutes next environmental
impact the carbon dioxide from burning
that fuel accounts for two percent of
global emissions that's one billion tons
of CO2 every year there are lower carbon
Alternatives but they face massive
hurdles one option is biofuels making
aircraft fuel from plants or trees but
the amount of land required for that is
immense for instance to make today's
Global jet fuel demand from Timber would
require the annual Harvest from a forest
five times the size of Egypt every year
jet fuel can also be made synthetically
by blending CO2 extracted from the air
and hydrogen from water but that process
requires eye-watering amounts of energy
to power all the aircraft today using
synthetic fuels would need about 25 to
40 percent of the world's entire
electricity generation or does hydrogen
and for the aviation sector it needs to
be in liquid form and flights drink
millions of gallons that we simply don't
have Europe's entire green liquid
hydrogen production currently could only
fuel one flight a day from London to Los
Angeles
so in a week when many people are
jetting off on holiday and the
government launched its jet zero
strategy I went down to the farnborough
air show aviation's massive sales
conference
being here at farnborough leaves me a
little bit conflicted
it's been a huge admirer of human
Ingenuity and inventiveness it's
enriched and improved our lives in so
many ways but when it comes to making
Aviation truly sustainable and climate
friendly I wonder if it's met its match
but this is a star
it's a battery driven Air Taxi capable
of taking four passengers about a
hundred miles so not really denting bulk
passenger transport
I know it's a bit of a cliche but it is
very James bondy
[Music]
it's British built and has some high
profile admirers who'll soon have more
time for a getaway the government has
just published updated plans to end the
climate impact of Aviation with a
promise to never let the sector's
emissions exceed 2019 levels and make
domestic flight Net Zero by 2040. it's
called jet zero hello prime minister Tom
Heap from Sky are we going faster off
towards low carbon Aviation get zeros
going very well but but we we can always
go faster
looking around the show it's clear that
reality is well behind rhetoric
this is the only zero emission plane
that could carry me over Britain today
[Music]
I've got to clear my leg past the
joystick that's it oh
once you're in you're in he's comfy oh
it's nice you got the standard
instrument panel with a six-pack I'm
tempting to say chocks away
when it comes to getting the big beasts
they're born in a climate friendly way
we've barely got off the ground
when you look out of these can you tell
which ones have got Rolls-Royce engines
with them well well they'll be big ones
time to talk to the boss of one of the
big engine makers Warren is sustainable
Aviation really a contradiction in terms
it's like sort of dry water or virginal
pregnancy it's uh it's certainly not
that much of a contradiction in terms in
fact it's it's now raised on debtor at
the moment is uh to ensure that Society
can benefit from all the benefits that
flying has bought for the last 100 years
but ensure that we can do it in a way
that doesn't cook the planet in future
Warren says that powering big planes
like this on zero carbon fuels like
electricity or hydrogen is unlikely for
20 years so the current suggestion is to
make liquid hydrocarbon fuel not from
oil but either from plants that would be
biofuel or synthetically from captured
CO2 and green hydrogen these are known
somewhat optimistically as sustainable
Aviation fuels if I want to buy some
sustainable aviation fuel today the
chances are the source of carbon is a
biofuel of some kind the real answer
isn't bio because we won't have the
scale we're not really solving the
problem you're running into issues of
biodiversity and all of those sorts of
you certainly I'm the land take to
supply biofuel for Aviation is
extraordinary that's why it's not
sustainable I think it's in it has a
role to play as a sort of small
transition because we have to get the
sort of biofuel ecosystems up and
running to then eventually move over to
synthetic we haven't got the land for
biofuels for aircraft no no we haven't
and that's why you need to do direct
carbon capture
and green hydrogen Productions to put
the synthetic aviation fuel together
that's the only way we're going to get
scale without running into the
biodiversity challenges direct air
capture and green hydrogen are
Technologies in their infancy and
they're very expensive are people going
to have to pay more for climate-friendly
flight surely that's inevitable
ultimately if if people want to continue
to enjoy the benefits of Aviation and do
it in a carbon freeway there's there's
going to be an increase in cost
the aviation business Prides itself on
achieving what was once thought to be
impossible it gets these things to fly
after all but with current technology
connecting the planet without cooking it
looks a little pie in the sky
well if you like aircraft the farmer Air
Show really is a toy box well the
numbers behind our analysis today come
from the aviation impact accelerator at
Cambridge University and their program
manager Beth Barker is with me here in
the studio Beth just before we get into
the numbers why was it felt necessary to
set up your organization
so when it comes to getting Aviation to
Net Zero the time scales are short and
the technology is uncertain so the
University of Cambridge set up the
aviation impact accelerator to bring
together Global expertise to work on the
numbers and model Pathways to Net Zero
so it's kind of a benchmark of numbers
we can all agree on exactly now one of
the things we've heard a lot about we
heard from the boss of Rolls Royce there
was biofuels he wasn't particularly keen
on them but America especially they are
considered to be part of the
climate-friendly answer for flying
yeah definitely and what's exciting is
they're available now in small
quantities but the big challenge is
feedstock availability
so if you look at 2019 Aviation burnt
the equivalent of 1 200 calories per
person per day it's going to interrupt
you there because that's an
extraordinary figure I mean men and
women need either side of 2 000 calories
a day to be healthy so more than half of
our calorie demand for food is is taken
up or would be taken up by by flying
exactly and our technical experts at the
aviation impact accelerator estimate
that it's likely by 2050 that calorie
for calorie Aviation demand could
outstrip food consumption and as we
heard it takes up an awful lot of land
now the other thing we heard a lot about
was hydrogen of course it doesn't emit
CO2 when you burn it is it the Silver
Bullet
it's not the Silver Bullet but it is
really exciting
hydrogen is a different type of fuel and
what we've got to remember is it's a
third the weight of Aviation current
aviation fuel that's a huge Advantage
but it's about four times the volume
which is a challenge so what we're going
to need is bigger complete redesigned
bigger aircraft with a bigger fuselage
now we've got one of these planes
potential sort of images of what a
hydrogen plane could look like and I can
see it's much more bulky it's more
voluminous the kind of wing is part of
the body that's that's to kind of
contain all that hydrogen is it yeah
exactly so you've got to keep the tanks
in there with the hydrogen and then of
course the people and Freight that need
to be on there too yeah
um now it's not just about what we burn
it's not just about the CO2 I gather
when it comes to climate impact of
flying there are other things that
affect global warming as well what are
they exactly so we've got to look at as
well as CO2 the non-co2 emissions and
these include nox nitrogen oxide soot
and water vapor and together these can
create water vapor trails or
condensation Trails often called
contrails yeah these are the things we
see the streaks in the sky we see behind
planes when they break up they kind of
form a thin blanket of cloud don't they
does that have a bit of an insulating
warming effect it does it's very
complicated and what I must emphasize is
that science here is uncertain and a lot
more research needs to be done but our
technical experts think that if you look
at all the non-co2 effects from
emissions that the climate warming
impact is equivalent to or greater than
the CO2 impact on its own wow so we've
already heard that CO2 could be two
percent of humankind's emissions this
could double it could be four percent
that's huge exactly and so government
and Industry must manage these as well
um this all makes me think that
technological fixes to making flying
climate friendly are still a very long
way off
it's a really big challenge there are
solutions but we've got to bring
expertise together to get there and of
course we've got to remember that lots
of other sectors are working towards
using these resources to get to net zero
two Beth thanks very much I really
enjoyed this this deep dive into the sky
if that makes sense into the figures
we've got thanks so much well a sobering
conclusion for those with an appetite
for mini breaks weekend getaways or
Global business conferences so is the
answer limiting the amount we fly carbon
taxis frequent flyer penalties that's
what we'll be discussing later in the
show
and our colleagues have done a bit more
digging with Beth's data from the
University of Cambridge which you'll be
able to find online together with all
our other climate coverage just head to
our website or the Sky News app
and we Endeavor here to answer some of
the unknowns about climate change
unsurprisingly we've had several
questions along similar lines this week
Chuckles Magoo asks on Instagram how
exactly are the fires around London
attributed to the Heat Wave and on the
Sky News app mags asked if it's possible
that a fire could start with no human
input like barbecues or cigarettes well
we'll have an answer for those for you
after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show on Sky
News and we've had all sorts of
questions from viewers this week about
climate change the Heat Wave and
wildfires well let's get some clarity
and some answers from Siobhan Robbins
who's been reporting on the devastating
fires in France this week
climate change impacts wildfires like
these and makes them more likely here's
why foreign
needs three things the right weather
some fuel and a spark if climate change
didn't exist we'd still have wildfires
but without global warming there would
be far fewer fires and they'd be less
likely to spread as far
the oxygen in the hot dry windy weather
helps to feed the Flames meaning they
can quickly get out of control
[Music]
in current conditions these fires are
self-perpetuating they're burning more
intensely and for longer than Nature's
been able to adapt to which means it's
harder for forests to regenerate that
leaves space for more flammable plants
like grasses and shrubs to move in
perfect Tinder for future fires
hot air acts like a sponge it draws out
water from the soil plants and trees
which crisps everything up and creates
the perfect kindling for a fire
the hotter the air the more water it's
able to hold so when there's a heat wave
all the organic matter on the ground is
quickly dried to a crisp add in
long-term temperature increases in
global warming and even deep rooted
trees and plants can dry out creating a
whole lot of fuel for the fires
these fires can ignite naturally simply
by the intense heat of the Sun but more
often they're caused by us a discarded
cigarette or a campfire that gets out of
control in these hot and dry conditions
and if you want any of your questions
answered you can scan the QR code on the
screen right now or go to any of our
social media accounts where you can add
your questions in the comments
well earlier in the show we heard how
the technological fixes to removing the
global warming impact of flight are
fraught with difficulty yet the
government's jet zero strategy published
this week is called guilt free flying
does that seem credible or is the only
certain way to shrink the carbon
footprint of flight to fly less I've
been out to ask
I've come out to the top of one of the
buildings here at Sky not least because
we're quite near Heathrow so we might
see one or two planes taking off and I'm
here with a couple of people who are
absolutely steeped in all things
Aviation that's Helena Bennett from the
green Alliance and also Matt Gorman
who's chair of sustainable Aviation and
they are an industry body
um Helena first of all what did you make
of the the jet zero strategy that came
out this week does it deliver as the
government hopes guilt-free fly
uh no it's the simple answer there are
many reasons for that I think the
biggest thing for us is the fact that
government is placing very big bets on
technology to decarbonize the aviation
sector and right now that technology
just doesn't exist it's not at scale
it's not deployed it's not commercially
available at the moment and there's a
big chunk of emissions that are going to
be left over in 2050 that we're going to
need to offset some way we know offsets
are limited whether they're Engineers or
whether they're natural solutions
and what the climate change committee
has said and recommended to government
is that we need to think about how much
we're flying and at the moment there's a
pump for transport is projecting around
a 70 increase in passenger numbers by
2050. that's an extra 200 million
passengers a year just before we get on
to this whole idea of managing or
perhaps cutting the amount we fly Matt I
mean this whole idea of guilt flea
flying can we fly guilt-free today in
environmental terms increase
increasingly not quite but increasingly
and I think actually this week to come
back to your first question it was a
real Landmark from the government
because it sets out a path to Net Zero
by 2050 but also interim targets and
ambition to make 2019 the year of Pete
carbon uh from Aviation and shows that
actually we can grow and get to Net Zero
and there's three main ways we'll do
that efficiency which is a kind of
Baseline assumption using less fuel
modernizing the airspace in the skies
above us and operating more efficiently
on the ground using lighter and more
efficient aircraft but that alone won't
get us to Net Zero so we need
sustainable Aviation fuels low carbon
proven today but more expensive than
kerosene too many government policies to
help scale them up and hydrogen in
future for zero emission shortages
Helena you're talking about basically us
flying less why is that desirable and
how on Earth could it be achieved so
we're not saying we need to fly less
from what we're doing today but it's the
fact that government are projecting such
a huge increase in the future so what
the climate change committee has
recommended which is what we're also
suggesting government does is introduce
what they're calling a demand management
framework which sees no net expansion of
airports across the UK but it still sees
an increase in 25 of passengers up to
2050 and that's kind of offset by you
know improvements in efficiency and
capacity Etc let's get to the
nitty-gritty here do we need for
instance a frequent fly attack so if I'm
someone who flies just once a year to go
on holiday to New York or whatever I
don't pay any more but if I'm going
regularly I should pay a tax for that
that choice yeah that's something that
we are hoping government will introduce
eventually and it's a it will be a
really good way of seeing you know
actual decreases and the number of
people that are flying very frequently
whether it's people that are taking 12
holidays a year or people that are
flying for business very regularly Matt
frequent flyer taxes no we don't support
them and we don't support demand
management largely because of the
amazing things that Aviation gives us
and by the way this isn't just in the UK
this is around the world you know
businesses connecting their products and
and people to customers
um people staying in touch with friends
and family exploring other parts of the
world and by the way the real growth in
aviation is less in the UK it's in many
other parts of the world the idea that
globally government's going to limit
demand I just don't see happening which
is why we have to find other Solutions
well we we say we have to but as we've
shown there they are incredibly
difficult and aren't you trying to have
a version of having your cake and eating
or saying we want all these great things
but you're not prepared to admit to what
it really means for the climate which is
a great little woman not at all I am
passionate about taking the carbon out
of flying so we can enjoy the benefits
of Aviation the UK sector was the first
to commit to Net Zero the first of any
Aviation sector this is a commitment so
you know the deliveries
we published a detailed plan of how to
get there the government's done a huge
amount of work and by the way the UN
body that regulates Aviation published a
huge study showing that sustainable
Aviation fuels and and hydrogen for
short haul can get us to Net Zero
alongside the removals that Helena
talked about which by the way will be
part of the picture as well and the Matt
does make a point doesn't it you know
there is a a small chance that you might
get some sort of frequent fly attacks
politically through here although I
think everyone has their doubts the idea
that that's going to happen in China or
India is for the birds isn't it
I mean to be honest that's not really
what this conversation's about we're
talking about UK yeah it's about the
global impact of aviation in the UK with
a with as much as the first country to
have such a it is it is an ambitious
strategy uh and we're the only ones that
have kind of got it really nailed down
to a year by year set of targets up to
2050 so you know we as a country have
said we're going to include
International Aviation and shipping
emissions in future carbon budgets so
we've now got a responsibility to make
sure that those flights that we're
accounting for are talked about in it
properly just a very very quick one each
carbon off setting I know it's by no
means perfect should passengers be doing
it now Matt uh yes they should be doing
it more we need governments to invest we
need industry to invest in natural
climate Solutions than engineer rooms
okay carbon offsetting now better than
nothing uh big question massively
depends it should be something that
airlines are looking at not necessarily
passengers and we have to make sure that
they are properly done robust and not
damaging to the natural environment or
land use at all
my thanks to Matt Gorman and Helena
Bennett well I hope that's given you an
insight into the exciting Tech yet epic
challenges facing the airline industry
the daily climate show is on next week
so take a look at that if you can that's
at 3 30 P.M every day and one footnote
on the hot week it has led to a bumper
Harvest of soft fruit like strawberries
thanks very much floor manager Jeff so
why not nip down to the shops and you
might find yourself a bargain bye
not bad
[Music]